cbs news medical contributor dr david
agus
joins us now to talk about all this dr
agus good morning good to see you
hey vlad good morning happy thanksgiving
happy thanksgiving to you so millions of
americans traveled for the holidays they
gathered with their loved ones
now they're traveling back home so what
kinds of precautions
should they be thinking about as they
head home
well you know every holiday to date
during this pandemic 10
or so days after the holiday there's
been a dramatic increase in cases in the
united states
and it will certainly happen with this
one going into this one we had record
numbers
prior ones we had lower numbers and
there was still spread so the more
virus you have going in the more there
will be going out obviously
so you know your risk if you had that
wayward cousin who goes out all the time
or the uncle who doesn't stay home
you've potentially been exposed and you
need to go home and what we now say the
cdc is you know 14 days
is optimal for quarantine seven to ten
days with the test at the end
is acceptable now and so you need to
assess your own risk if it was just you
and grandma
you probably don't need to do anything
but we really don't want you going back
to where you were
and spreading the virus let's talk about
children and older students they're
headed back to school what kind of
precautions
should they be thinking about what
should parents know
well schools are obviously a vector is
that no matter how you try
and you put pods you know where kids
interact only with their pot but they're
going to be interactions
at school so if your child was
potentially
exposed or higher risk you need to
really impress upon him or her
the role of quarantine and when they get
to school to make sure that they
interact with their pot only
and not uh you know a broad section of
school whether it's university
at schools make sure they wear masks and
everyone else wear masks
the public health rules we all know now
we just have to enforce them as we get
closer to a vaccine the more we enforce
them
the more lives they're going to be saved
and that is the most important thing
as you know today is black friday
typically that means huge crowds
i'm guessing your advice is look you
wanted to get together with your family
that is understandable on some level but
stay away from the shop stay away from
the crowds online shopping is the way to
go
oh yeah there's this new thing called
the internet it is amazing
and certainly the more you shop online
the safer you are
if you want to support a local store
that does not have online shopping
call ahead and you know know what you
want and have them deliver a curbside
open the back window of your car
and have them place it inside where you
do the transaction over the phone
we all just have to be as safe as
possible and the more we
limit risk the better we're all going to
do and hopefully there's light at the
end of the tunnel again vaccines are
coming so please
behave today so we can all be healthy
tomorrow
and finally doctor hospitalizations hit
record levels in the united states
we are anticipating a post thanksgiving
surge it's got a lot of people
worried are you worried about that and
what could the numbers look like
in two weeks well i mean
i am very very worried that we're going
to see a dramatic increase in
hospitalizations and deaths from this
virus unfortunately
and it's going to be 10 to 14 days now
the hospitalization and about a week lag
when we start to see the increase in
deaths and we've seen that with
every other holiday so you know i'm
saddened in many respects because we're
nearing the end and i know covet fatigue
unfortunately is going to take
significantly more lives when you look
at the hospitalization levels we have
now and you look at the suffering now of
patients in the hospital it's only going
to get worse unfortunately
all right dr david agus here's hoping
that it doesn't but the numbers
are what they are they are very stark we
appreciate your time doctor thank you